[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le mardi à 13
septembre merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
on commence tout de suite avec les
titres
problèmes dans les transports publics à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines aujourd'hui la
ligne c du rer et les années ou ont été
fortement perturbés le point à suivre
dans cette édition
est le dépôt officiel des candidatures
est terminé pour la primaire de la
droite et du centre dans les yvelines
trois élus étaient engagés nous y
reviendrons et enfin du vélo avec l
inauguration de la vélo c'est nice cette
piste cyclable qui relie paris pau mont
saint michel en passant par les aigus et
je vous le disais en titre la
circulation des trains a été fortement
perturbée ce mardi à 13 septembre en
gare de saint quentin en yvelines une
perturbation causée par la coupure de
ligne lui dont les deux sens de
circulation
près de 59 à 55 mille voyageurs pardon
ont été touchés selon les chiffres de la
sncf les précisions avec nicolas landry
et mickaël millero
difficile de se rendre de saint quentin
en yvelines à la défense ce mardi 13
septembre la ligne u est coupée dans les
deux sens de circulation depuis 4 heures
35 du matin en cause une panne
d'aiguillage au niveau de porchefontaine
ce dysfonctionnement a aussi posé des
difficultés sur le rer c aucun train ne
peut circuler entre les gares de
viroflay rive gauche et saint quentin en
yvelines les passagers doivent avoir
recours à des alternatives notamment la
ligne n entraînant certaines
conséquences j'ai plein d'amis du cou
qui sont fait avoir ils sont arrivés en
retard et en quoi je suis venu
aujourd'hui à la défense j'avais qu'à
l'aller on était un trophée d'engranger
c'est la merde quoi donc je vais
retourner à nassian pilleurs j'appris de
trading à quoi je confirme que j'ai des
gros problèmes ce matin mes cheveux
noirs travail tue une heure de retard et
forcément mais bon sens pas très comment
un moment un peu marre quoi ouais on se
demande s'il faut pas acheter une
voiture est arrêtée elle était
transports en commun pour se rendre à la
défense il est conseillé d'emprunter le
rer c puis le tramway à partir d'issy
les moulineaux les agents de la sncf
sont actuellement sur le terrain pour
réparer le système le retour à la
normale du trafic sur la ligne e u
devrait se faire ce mercredi 14
septembre
et sur la ligne du rer c le trafic reste
interrompue de viroflay rive gauche
pardon vers saint quentin en yvelines
jusqu'en fin de soirée en conséquence et
les trains à destination de saint
quentin en yvelines sont terminus en
gare de juvisy et cela jusqu'à la fin du
service pour c'est qu'il est de la ligne
e u le trafic est également interrompue
sur l'ensemble de la ligne les guerres
de versailles chantiers de saint cyr et
de saint quentin en yvelines sont
accessibles par les trains des lignes n
en gare montparnasse est à présent
retour sur la venue de françois hollande
et de la ministre du travail mme myriam
el khomri hier à saint quentin en
yvelines dont locaux dit fuck up centres
spécialisés de la formation
professionnelle pour adultes une visite
officielle pour parler du plan 500000
une partie du plan d'urgence pour
l'emploi lancé en janvier dont
l'objectif est de doubler le nombre de
formations pour atteindre un million
cette année un milliard d'euros a été
alloué à la mise en oeuvre des actions
régionaliser selon l'elysée pour
françois hollande l'objectif de 500 me
leur formation sera atteint toujours
selon lui les 13 régions françaises tous
se sont engagés dans ce plan et le
nombre de personnes inscrites en
formation a augmenté de 70 % entre
décembre 2015 et août 2016 et politiques
toujours avec la primaire de la droite
et du centre on connaît désormais le nom
huit candidats qui ont reçu les
parrainages nécessaires pour espérer
être candidat à la présidentielle dans
les yvelines trois élus étaient en
course pour les pour des fortunes
diverses à chaque fois le point avec
nikola attendri et osman vendeur mais il
sera finalement le seul yvelinois en
lice pour la primaire de la droite et du
centre les 20 et 27 novembre prochains
jean frédéric poisson bénéficie d'un
statut particulier dans cette campagne
en qualité de président du parti
chrétien démocrate
ils n'étaient pas soumis à l'obstacle
des parrainages une aubaine pour
l'ancien maire de rambouillet déjà en
campagne depuis plusieurs mois nécessité
noah ne roule n'ai pas trouvé de
candidat qui défend une vision proche de
daniel ces candidats
communs qui suit arabes dans les comics
partage favorable de la france en europe
favorables à un rééquilibrage des
relations internationales
et encore une fois où j'ai d'affirmer
une
vraie différence à l'égard d'autres
entend
effectivement
lui n'avait que peu d'espoirs de réunir
les parrainages nécessaires pour le
souverainiste jacques myard député-maire
de maisons-laffitte
l'essentiel était ailleurs pour faire un
candidat à la présidence de la
république ou même un président de la
république on ne l'est pas le matin je
dirais simon avant dix ans je vais y
aller tout ça fait
donc un film et cancer mais j'ai atteint
mon objectif
c'est d'être dans le pré débat
pour m'exprimer sur les thèmes qui sont
les miennes à savoir leur établissement
la souveraineté de la france henri
guaino parlait d' escroquerie
démocratique pour évoquer la primaire
l'ancienne plume de nicolas sarkozy a
échoué lui aussi à rassembler les
parrainages suffisants sur sa
candidature et a donc décidé de se
présenter seul à l'élection
présidentielle le député de la 3e
circonscription des yvelines qui n'a pas
donné suite à nos demandes d'interview
devra désormais relever un autre
challenge obtenir le soutien de 500 élus
locaux pour espérer devenir président de
la république
et le mouvement apolitique en marche des
manuels macron prend de l'ampleur l'ex
ministre de l'économie pourrait bientôt
annoncer officiellement sa candidature
dans la course à l'elysée il rallie de
nombreux soutiens dans toute la france
comme dans les yvelines sur notre
territoire ils seraient près de vingt
mille à avoir le rejoint le mouvement en
marche et d'emmanuel macron selon son
responsable asie françois n'diaye
référent illinois je vous propose de
l'écouter il était hier l'invité de
wilfrid est enrichie dans le 7-8 les
invités on comptait en attente de la
sortie du gouvernement des modèles
macron et je peux vous dire que sur la
seule journée de sa sortie 12 mai
d'adhérents supplémentaires c'est
colossal en parle à l'échelle nationale
en à l'échelle nationale son département
sur le département particulièrement on
n'a pas encore les chiffres normalement
ça devrait sortir très peu de façon
ciblée mais
nous sommes aujourd'hui à 75000 un peu
plus d'adhérents sur l'ensemble du
territoire je peux vous dire que le
département des yvelines est très très
mobilisé et nous faisons je pense partie
des premiers départements en termes de
nombre et particulièrement ce qui ce qui
me frappe dans cette mobilisation c'est
que nous avons des gens qui viennent de
toutes catégories sociales ce que
j'allais vous demandez le profil un
petit peu d de tout âge toute catégorie
sociale de tout âge et beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup avec un fort taux de premier
engagement
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est
frappant c'est qu'au moment où les
français se désengage de la chose
politique nous avons de plus en plus de
gens qui nous rejoignent et pour qui
c'est le premier engagement ce qui est
mon cas d'ailleurs si je voudrais
[Musique]
approximatif je dirais sur en faisant un
petit calcul à partir de ceux qui sont
sur versailles sachant qu'on n'a pas
pris une douzaine d'agglomération on
tournerait autour de
millions de disques et quand même assez
conseil souhaiterait qu'on s'accroche
peu samedi nous avons réuni les membres
qui souhaitait participer aux réunions
qui vont venir il va s'étendre dans la
phase de structuration du parti nous
attendions j'allais lire x personnes et
nous avons le x 3 et prenons à présent à
la direction de coignières plus de
sécurité pour la ville c'est la volonté
du maire la décision a été prise avant
l'été un poste de police municipale va
être va être créée et va s'ajouter aux
300 emplois à temps plein à sdp déjà
existants on écoute tout de suite les
précisions du maire jean-pierre sevestre
cette nouveauté est selon lui nécessaire
pour la commune nous aurons un
responsable de police et nous aurons un
agent administratif chargé de l'accueil
de la population et des personnes qui
veulent bien sûr intervenir au sein de
la police municipale mais également
quatre agents qui pourront par binôme
intervenir pour des missions de
proximité car actuellement il me semble
qu'il est indispensable qu'il y a une
police de proximité
dans nos différents quartiers de
coignières vous l'avez entendu les
agents effectueront des missions de
proximité ils arriveront notamment sur
le code de l'urbanisme sur le
stationnement et les problèmes
d'incivilités
et c'est une nouvelle qui ravira
sûrement à les cyclistes cet après midi
au château de la madeleine à cheuvreux
avait lieu l'inauguration du parcours de
la baie losséni dans les yvelines un
itinéraire reliant jouy en josas a
énoncé il s'inscrit dans le parcours
global de laver losséni une voie
cyclable pourront paris de haut qui
couvre paris jusqu'au mont saint michel
les précisions de camille lambert
60 km reliant jouy en josas à heymans et
c'est la piste cyclable inauguré mardi
13 septembre à chevreuse au château de
la madeleine le conseil départemental a
présenté ce parcours un trajet qui
s'inscrit dans un projet global celui de
la vélo ceni 450 km courant de paris au
mont saint michel ce que je trouve très
bien dans ce type de projet c'est qu'il
est vraiment transversale on traverse
une région
on traverse plusieurs régions traverse
plusieurs départements on traverse
plusieurs communes tout le monde s'y met
avec un fédérateur un vecteur fédérateur
qu'est sept vélos scénique pour ce
nouvel itinéraire le département a
investi plus de 3 millions d'euros la
région ile de france les collectivités
concernées par ce tracé ont également
subventionné le projet au cours de leur
périple les cyclistes sont amenés à
découvrir les richesses du territoire un
moyen de favoriser le tourisme nous
cherchons véritablement à faire un
développement autour de cela avec des
restaurants des hôtels des gîtes des
maisons d'accueil de façon à ce que cela
devienne vraiment un tourisme en
développement économique c'est le
fondamental du département nous avons
une vraie volonté aujourd'hui au niveau
du département de développer tous qu'ils
sont tous les pépites des pics culturel
la patrimonial ou naturelles des
dizaines de curiosité sont à découvrir
en pédalant cinq sites inscrits au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco ponctuent
le parcours de la vélo ceni au total
elles traversent eux quatre régions et
huit départements
ont fini à ce journal en musique
hassanie dernier a eu lieu la deuxième
édition du crazy temps le festival au
parc de folleville 2-1 valait grignon
six concerts rock reggae funk et blues
ainsi que des activités pour enfants
étaient au programme de cette journée
qui a pu profiter d'un temps estival
regardez ce reportage a signé blu ray le
falun et patrick gp dixmude a
pendant 45 minutes de 7 le groupe de
reggae mal mal a fait vibrer les
planches du festival crazy tonnes
organisée pour la deuxième fois dans le
parc de folleville de thiverval grignon
l'occasion pour les sept manches whoopi
blinois de faire passer leur message
près de chez eux un message d'unité donc
fait les grandes phrases mais ça reste
toujours des bonnes valeurs donc l'unité
pour toutes les communautés donc on est
content de jouer à quatre avec plein de
groupes plein de styles différents et
justement on est là aussi pour
représenter le reggae musique à travers
tous ces groupes de rock donc on lâche
pas la faire on est là on est très
content et côté rock justement les cinq
membres du groupe cartes sont venus
jouer leur musique influencé par la pop
britannique d où des beatles et des
kicks c'est une manière de jouer en fait
c'est une très bonne ambiance la scène
est magnifique il fait beau on est très
bien accueilli pour cette deuxième
édition ce festival de musiques
actuelles gratuit tend à favoriser les
groupes locaux mais a surtout un
objectif majeur mettre en avant la
musique la musique c'est un langage
international
auquel on a vraiment très attaché et
donc c'est avant tout la musique et
l'art musical
quarante bénévoles et 40 musiciens on
devrait cette année pour célébrer la
musique au coeur des yvelines une
nouvelle édition de ce festival est déjà
prévue pour 2017
c'est à présent la fin de cette édition
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivis je
vous retrouve demain pour une nouvelle
édition du journal et vous souhaite une
excellente souris
[Musique]